- My next guest is crazy talented.
I mean, he's written so many songs
you don't even know he's written them.
He sold more than 20
million albums worldwide
and won three Grammys not too shabby.
Now he's back as a judge
every Tuesday evening
on the hit NBC show, my
sister's favorite show,
World Of Dance, check it out.
(dramatic electronic music)
- Yeah.
Hey, hey, hey.
- All right y'all, give it up for Ne-Yo!
Hey, what's up Ne-Yo, how you doing?
- How are you, love?
Good to see you.
- I am hanging in there.
I think we're all just,
it's a crazy year this year.
- To say the least, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, it's a lot, but
it's nice to see you again.
And how have you actually been handling
the craziness, all the lockdown?
'Cause you've kids with you.
- Yeah, yeah I have
four beautiful children,
four very loud, very energetic children.
- [Kelly] Yeah. (chuckles)
- And they are thoroughly enjoying
all the downtime with dad,
they really truly are.
And to be honest, I am too, I am too.
I mean, my condolences and my heart
goes out to anybody that lost anybody
to COVID, and the whole situation.
But as far as the quarantine,
I'm rarely at home anyway,
I travel a whole lot,
and this was kind of an opportunity
for me to kinda, like
reconnect with my kids.
You know, I don't know
if you knew personally,
but you know, before quarantine,
you know me and my wife
were talking divorce,
but the quarantine kind
of allowed us the time
to sit down and really kind
of lock back into each other.
So like.
- Wow!
- We're good now, there's
no divorce happening,
everything's good.
- Oh, wow!
- But yeah man!
Again it almost feels wrong to say that
this whole COVID-19 quarantine thing
was kind of a blessing to me.
- Wow, what a beautiful thing
that it ended up working out.
And you took such a negative situation,
it could have been a really negative thing
and made it a positive with this pandemic
and everything going on.
- Absolutely.
- But on another positive
that you've just released
a song called "U 2 Luv."
- U 2 Luv!
- What is it about?
And what is the inspiration?
Is it your life?
- So "U 2 Luv," featuring Jeremih,
by the way, shout out to Jeremih.
The song basically is about,
the tagline is I only want you to love,
I don't want nobody else.
So it's basically just talking about
you and that one person and mind you,
we recorded the song before
the quarantine happened.
But considering the quarantine,
it's kinda like the perfect quarantine bay
to playing the song you know what I mean.
(laughs)
You and the quarantine bae.
- Yeah!
- Sitting in front
of the couch with this
plan in the background,
it's just a perfect scene,
it makes perfect sense.
- Yeah, all right!
Okay, so you did something
that I like vowed to never do again,
because this is a very hard thing to do.
I've sang at a few funerals in my life.
- Whoa!
- And it's just the hardest scenario ever
if you know them or if you
don't, it doesn't matter.
Because you're seeing other
people's pain regardless,
and it's just painful.
- Yeah!
- But you actually performed
at George Floyd's funeral.
- [Ne-Yo] Yeah.
- [Kelly] So how did you get involved?
- [Ne-Yo] I believe that
the family reached out.
I got the information from my manager,
so I didn't speak directly to the family,
but I believe they reached out
and asked if I would sing.
And, I mean of course I said, "Yeah."
So we got down there,
I tried to sit a little
further back, you know,
'cause I didn't want the
moment to be about me at all.
You know what I mean?
Like I didn't wanna do
the celebrity thing,
I didn't want that.
But when they saw me,
they pulled me off to a closer pew
and I'm like, "All
right, all right, cool."
So I'm sitting there
and I get up on stage,
and the second I got up
there I look in the audience,
and his daughter sitting
right in front of me.
And then all I could see in
that moment was my daughter.
And it broke, I broke, I couldn't.
- It's the hardest thing to do.
- Yeah.
- This thing...
- I couldn't get my words together
with what I wanted to
say, that came out wrong.
Some people misunderstood,
what I meant by that whatever.
- I know that's kind of the bad thing too.
'Cause I feel like,
I heard there was a bit of
blow back from the funeral.
Did that hit you hard
to where you were like, "Wait,
that was totally missed.
I got, that was twisted."?
- You know what, initially, I won't lie.
Initially it did 'cause I'll be honest.
When my manager called
me and told me about,
what was being said or whatever,
and I instantly got upset like, What?
Like how could anybody really think
that I would stand up
at this man's funeral
in front of this man's family,
and mean anything negative or wrong about,
like how could anybody make that mistake?
Right, so.
- Yeah.
- So, I got upset and my response was,
you know what, intelligent
people know what I meant.
- Yeah.
- And anybody ignorant,
I ain't worried about it.
But then my manager had to catch me.
He was like,
no, that's not what this is.
This moment is really,
really important, okay?
The least you could do
is take a few minutes
to make sure that people understand
what it is you're saying, okay?
Because ignorance is division.
And we don't need division
right now, all right?
We need to do this right now.
- Wow!
- So take a second.
Explain what it is you meant,
not because anyone is owed an explanation,
but because it's the right thing to do
in order for unity to be
part of the narrative,
not division, you know?
So I took it upon myself,
I went into the comments
and I answered some people.
Somebody said, "He wasn't
sacrificed, he was murdered."
And I'm like, okay well,
in the realm of a lot of sacrifices,
they kind of involve death, I mean,
it's unfortunate that his death was
the spark that caused this energy
that is slowly but surely
creating change for us.
But the truth of the
matter is this man's life
was sacrificed in order
for this to happen.
Now I don't think that was
the reasoning behind it initially,
of course, the cops killed him
and it was meant for wicked.
But we then took something
that was meant for wicked
and turned it into a positive.
- Yeah, no, I agree.
You're such a great man,
you're such a good dude, it's so cool.
I am back with Ne-Yo, and you can see him
- Yeah, yeah.
- On World Of Dance Tuesdays on NBC,
seriously, my sister is
obsessed with your show.
(chuckles)
So have you been missing your
friends at World Of Dance?
Have you been missing Derek and J-Lo?
- Yeah, man, I really truly have,
- Yeah!
- So here's the thing.
So the show is not live.
Okay, that's no secret to
anyone, the show is not live.
We shot the last show, the
season finale, pretty much
the day that this whole
COVID-19 madness began,
- Lucky!
- The day that they started
sending people home,
was the day that we shot the final show.
So we decided that for the
first half of the show,
we wanted to break it down,
like we wanted to make
the contestants earned
that big beautiful stage with
the LED screen and all that,
we wanted to make them earn that.
So the qualifier rounds
and the dual rounds
are all done in a warehouse.
Now, I think we're a little
bit ahead of our time,
(child wailing)
Hey, hold on buddy, hold on.
(chuckles)
I think we were,
a little bit ahead of time because,
sort of qualifying rounds.
- [Child] Oh, hi!
- I don't do that this guy, hold on.
Say hi.
- [Kelly] Hi!
- Say hello.
- Hi!
Oh my gosh, you're adorable.
(laughs loudly)
- You wanna say hi too, come on, come on.
Come on say hi.
- Hi.
- Hi, oh my gosh, you have
a beautiful smile too.
Hello?
- Hi.
- All right, I'll be with
you in a second, okay?
- That happens with me all
the time too, you're good.
(laughs)
- Right, so, what I'm saying is,
I think we might've been ahead of our time
because the qualifier rounds,
now that had to walk in
and it's literally just us and just them.
There's no audience, there's no lights,
and all of that.
- It's very quarantinish.
- Yeah, yeah.
But like before we even knew,
like were social distancing
before we knew that we
needed social distance,
like it's kind of a cool thing.
- But like okay, so speaking
of dances and dance craze,
I remember, I mean,
I'm not a great dancer.
I'm like that girl that can
like dance remotely okay.
Like you know I'm in a club, so it's like,
but there's always been a dance craze.
Like I mean, I just, you know,
the moonwalk or dabbing
or even the Roger Rabbit,
that had its moment.
- Yeah!
(laughs)
- Like everything has its moment.
But so the name always seems random,
you know, of whatever dance craze it is.
So when your friend Derek Hough was here,
we asked him if he
could create some dances
based on random phrases I gave him.
- So you just gave me random?
- I am gonna call out random
things to make up a dance.
- Okay.
- Yeah, no pressure don't suck.
everyone's watching.
(audience laughing)
Okay, the plunger.
(upbeat music)
(audience laughing)
Okay, how about the Rumba?
(audience cheering)
The Griffin Door.
- Wow!
(laughs loudly)
- That's the drill, that's the drill.
- That's a C grade.
All right, so we just
showed the tape of Derek,
obviously killing it in the video.
He did really well.
- Yeah, right.
- So I just feel like Ne-Yo,
you might be able to
one-up him one, and also
I feel like I kinda like
to participate this time
'cause I'm super competitive.
So I was just asking.
- Wait a minute,
are you challenging me,
to a dance-off right now?
- I am dance challenging you.
The next time that you are in my studio,
we can be around each other.
I'll even be six feet
apart from you, fine.
But I'm challenging you to the same game.
My producer, I don't know the words,
they'll call out a name and something
and we have to do it.
And I'm challenging you,
and I think that I will whip your behind,
that's what I'm saying.
- You know what?
(laughs)
The competitor in me
is outraged right now,
and I humbly accept your challenge, yes.
- Good, I like it, I like it.
I'm gonna bring so much
heat, but in the end,
(laughs)
I mean, I'm just saying like
when we can also go out and go to parties,
I always like to ask dancers
because I'm not a dancer,
what is like a good, cool chill move?
If I'm just like, if
I'm there at the party
and everyone starts dancing and I'm like,
I don't wanna be to like,
all of a sudden I'm busting
out some choreography.
I just want like a cool move
that's more than a side step.
What would you give me?
- It's more than a side step okay?
- Yeah more than the side step.
- Because I'm side step king, okay?
- I like your side steps.
(chuckles)
- I've mastered the art of
dancing and not sweating.
Normally I'm dressed very nice,
I don't wanna sweat myself out.
- Oh my Gosh,
how do you do that?
- I've developed a dance technique,
that allows you to still look like
you know what you're
doing, but not sweat, okay?
- Okay.
- You said more than a two step,
because my two step game...
- More than a two step.
I got that one.
- Okay, my two step game is
very, very cool, you see that?
- Well maybe I need a better
two step game, teach me that.
- You see my feet?
- Yes.
- There are multiple two steps,
they'll say Papa Bear by the way, yeah.
- I know,
I was gonna say hey Papa bear.
- Okay!
(laughs)
So, there are multiple two steps, okay,
there's this typical thing here.
- Yeah.
- All right?
But then if you wanna
get fancy, you go here,
cross them over,
- Oh, across over.
Across over.
- You go a little.
- A little behind.
- Add a little something to it.
- Can you go switching it up?
- The switch up?
All of this counts as dancing.
You can do all of this while holding
your favorite beverage.
- A drink.
- And not spill it.
- Yes.
- Yes!
- I just need to work on the part
that you have mastered, not sweating,
because I am sweaty.
(laughs)
- Are you a natural sweater?
That's why I've been doing that.
- I am a natural, like on tour.
I'd look at my makeup
artist and apologize,
every time I go out on the
stage, 'cause I'm like,
everything you did was really pretty,
but in like seven minutes,
it's gonna be gone.
So, yeah, it's gonna be off.
- Completely, completely off.
- So wait, if I'm not,
if I'm holding a drink,
or like, what do I do with my hands?
'Cause I feel like, kind of like sometimes
- But see, that's okay.
- That's what makes it,
(laughs)
I don't know how to do it, but.
- Yeah I don't know this hands.
(laughs)
- That's what makes it so cool.
So I'm holding my phone in this hand,
but this would be the hand with the drink,
and the other hand you
can put in your pocket.
- [Kelly] Oh!
You're just feeling...
- Hey!
- Yeah.
- This is solely bad.
- One step at a time.
Having fun.
- You're having a good time.
- I'm too cool to move too much, exactly.
I'm way too cool to go out of my way
and sweat for everyone around.
No I'm gonna stay nice and dry,
dance cool with the mellow.
- Yes.
- And everyone's gonna look at me and go,
wow, look how cool that guy is
(laughs)
and he's not even dancing.
That's what happens.
- That's what I wanna be.
- That's what I'm gonna do
I'm telling you.
- I wanna be that person at the party.
'Man, she's cool,
she's not even trying, she's just
exuding excellence and awesomeness."
- Exactly.
(laughs)
- I love you man, and I'm so happy
for you and your family too.
I'm glad that this pandemic really helped
y'all in that sense, and
I think that's a beautiful thing,
when a family can work it out.
So way to go on that front
to both of y'all.
- Thank you so much for that.
- Yeah, and y'all be sure to catch
Ne-Yo, Derek Hough and J-Lo.
Every Tuesday on World Of Dance on NBC.
It's an amazing show.